bonjour william julie et merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france on l'a
dit la société amesys est accusé d'avoir
fourni un logiciel de cybersurveillance
au gouvernement kadhafi
alors pourquoi le gouvernement libyen
avait il besoin de ce logiciel
écoutez le gouvernement libyen on avait
besoin de façon certaine dans le cadre
du soulèvement
à l'époque de la population pour
surveiller et pouvoir ensuite interpellé
est malemenée torturé pour un grand
nombre de cas les personnes qui étaient
considérés comme des opposants au régime
alors comment se fait-il que cette
société française la société amesys se
retrouvent justement à collaborer avec
mouammar kadhafi
écoutez c'est tout l'objet de
l'information judiciaire qui a été
ouverte suite à la plainte déposée par
la fidh et la ldh
c'est au dossier est en cours donc
d'examen depuis maintenant 10 ans et le
fait extraordinaire qui vient de se
produire et que la société ou en tout
cas un certain nombre de ses animateurs
viennent d'être mises en examen c'est un
dossier qui est un dossier un peu le
miroir d'une autre procédure d'une autre
société avec laquelle d'ailleurs la
société amesys était en contact qui
s'appelle cosmos et qui a également le
fait l'objet d'investigations par le
même polo tribunal judiciaire de paris
investigation dont on dira peut-être un
mot dans une seconde qui s'est soldée
par un non lieu
mais pour des motifs juridiques qui a
priori risque de ne pas s'appliquer à
amesys est donc la décision de mise en
examen qui vient d'être prise par les
juges donnent l'idée que dix ans après
le début de ces investigations et bien
la justice à récolter des éléments qui
permettent de considérer qu'il y a des
indices graves et concordants selon les
termes juridiques pour que ces personnes
soient aujourd'hui formellement mise en
examen l'instruction va se dérouler et
pourra éventuellement déboucher ça ce
serait une autre première extraordinaire
sur le renvoi d'un certain nombre
d'individus devant une cour d'assises
parce que c'est bien d'un crime dont
nous parlons ici
vous parlez d'une enquête de dix ans
pourquoi si longtemps sont des enquêtes
qui sont tout d'abord difficile à mener
parce qu'il faut récolter un certain
nombre de preuves qui viennent de libye
les associations de jeunes de cités ont
fait un travail extraordinaire au permis
à ce que des ressortissants libyens
puissent être entendus par le juge
d'instruction de témoigner et c'est sans
doute aussi grâce à ces éléments
hostiles à des documents qui ont été
retrouvés après la chute de kadhafi en
libye et qui permettent aujourd'hui
d'acquérir la preuve certaine on ne sait
pas encore mais en tout cas des éléments
probants laissant penser que le
programme eagle parce que c'est le nom
du programme de surveillance qui avait
donc été vendue par cette société au
régime de kadhafi à cette époque et bien
que ce programme a été effectif
on a retrouvé des éléments permettant de
savoir que des conversations skype
facebook et autres gmail avait été
obtenue par les services de
renseignement grâce aux outils vendus
par amesys est cet élément-là
caractérisera sans doute dans
lordonnance finale du juge d'instruction
est bien le fait que cette société sts
avait à quoi allait servir les
dispositifs techniques qui était vendu à
la libye alors la société amesys est
donc mise en examen du côté judiciaire
quelles vont être les étapes dans les
semaines dans les mois à venir
écoutez je suppose que la défense de ces
individus va essayer peut-être de mettre
en place le même système que celui
qu'avait mis en place cosmos qui malgré
le non-lieu
a été un succès parce que dans
lordonnance de non lieu de cosmos les
juges ont considéré et bien que
l'élément était intentionnel pardon été
constituée et qu'il n'était pas possible
de soutenir qu'on ne savait pas avant
dans ces dispositifs d'ailleurs avec
l'aval des autorités françaises des
services de renseignement de la dgse
mais aussi pour le dossier libyen
à l'évidence des plus hautes autorités
de l'état on sait notamment que
l'intermédiaire
takieddine est aussi citée dans la vente
de ces matériels à l'époque et bien que
non seulement la société qu'ils ont des
ces dispositifs étaient forcément au
courant de ce à quoi il allait servir
mais qu'au delà de ça est bien certaine
autorité de l'état savait parfaitement
et bien qu'on était en train de vendre
des moyens de surveillance de masse qui
à l'évidence du la nature du régime dont
on parle est bien allé s'en servir pour
d'autres motifs que des motifs
éventuellement légitime de lutter contre
la criminalité ou le terrorisme
merci beaucoup à dire julie et d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur rtl frange
rappelle que vous êtes avocat spécialisé
en droit pénal et droit de l'homme et
extradition merci beaucoup bonne journée